but we're not done talking about fallout
for you so back to the big one you know
we love building stuff in our games and
if you think about building and crafting
fallout is kind of the perfect world to
do all of that in so like many things we
have gone completely overboard and
here's how it works in the game we're
allowing your character while playing to
rebuild and it works like this you can
scrap items in the world for materials
and then use those materials to build
the way you want and one of the great
things about having a fully dynamic game
engine is all of this just works in real
time rip it apart and fill the way you
want like the rest of the game this is
about making it your own experience we
want you to build and decorate and and
make yourself really a place you want to
live in a new home for yourself
and your best friend of course
as your settlement grows people will
arrive including certain traders they
have some of the best items in the game
for these people you will need to you
can plant food water and even power
generators all right so the generators
will power things through switches that
require power lights and other items and
then you run wires that connect them all
and again it just works you can also
build your own terminals that hook to
this power grid and then you could
control the various things and tweak
them all that the power lines are
connected to this includes things like
turrets
because you do want to build defenses
because your settlements can and will
get attacked by Raiders
so it's fun to build up something
yourself in the game that usually you'll
find that we have built for you
there are many large sites in the game
world where we allow you to build and
you can even run Brahmin caravans
between your settlements keep in mind
like most things we do this is an
optional part of the game that you can
do if you want to it's just one part of
a huge game but it's really really great
for Fallout we just absolutely love this
feature
and this crafting system carries over to
other things in the world so let's say
you want to build this scope and the
game will tell you you need these
components and those components are
found in all of the items in the world
so you could decide to build this scope
out of these you know say the microscope
a toy car or these you know duct tape an
alarm clock and such so we like to fill
our worlds with thousands of items that
you can interact with and now all of
them have purpose and here's what it
looks like in the game we do have over
50 base weapons and over 700
modifications for those weapons so you
could take a basic you know the laser
pistol from fallout is one of the base
weapons and then modify that and turn it
into something completely new
and you can even modify your own power
armor
you